being a non-binary person that sometimes
has the choice to either going into a
men's restroom looking like this you can
look at me looking like this it's just
interesting I thought this was a trans
debate that's what I thought nonbinary
Nary people fall under the trans
umbrella yeah so I don't know maybe you
could educate yourself a little bit on
that I think I think you figure out what
reality
is it is a safety concern for trans
women to share a Fe male restroom can
the agre please step
forward before we begin this episode we
know there's been a lot of anticipation
for this topic that is why we're excited
to release an Extended Cut of this
episode featuring all prompts on our
middleground patreon this is something
that you guys have been asking us about
for years and we're excited to finally
be able to do it and when you support
our patreon you help us to make Middle
Ground a show that truly provokes
understanding and creates human
connection and that is the point of
Middle Ground so now let's get into the
video
forward yeah
there's no it depends yes so I I think I
think that to start it off though too is
it's not necessarily saying that trans
women it all comes down to self ID when
we moved into a self ID process there
are a lot of people there are a lot of
men just simply self iding into being
trans women to utilize the female
restroom and to harm women I just be
there they're they're getting arousal
from just being there you know there was
a photo or it was a video that went
viral I think like just weeks ago with
some like whole man with a boner in the
woman's restroom and there's just some
poor woman filming it like am I just
supposed to like accept that this is
here so I think there's levels to it I
think that trans women who are actually
trans you know we're talking gender
dysphoria transitioned making the effort
you know probably once you reach a
certain point in your transition where
you can actually assimilate within that
space and not cause a disruptance that
would probably be the ideal time to
start doing that right whereas you know
across stresser who is emboldened to in
this current climate say that they're
trans because now anything is trans if
you say so uh that person should
probably stay absolutely out of women's
restrooms because you're there to get
your rocks off and the women are there
to take a poop and a pee so it's not the
same um and you know I really empathize
with women who you know have an issue
with it and and I can probably hear some
women commenting well how do I know the
difference between a fetishist and a
real trans person it's hard it's hard
however
that's the only Nuance that I know to
give to it which is there's different
reasons people are trans and some people
really are trans because they're horny
and some people are trans because they
really felt that way from you know a
young age or whatever see I agree to an
extent like when you go to
transition this is a fairly Universal
experience you know once you get to a
certain point of passing that's about
the time that you would start going into
the other bathroom as opposed to not
make the same sex uncomfortable once you
reach that point in your transition a
lot of things change but you know you
start to you start to see things from
another perspective you start to see
things from the perspective of a CIS
person yeah and I actually offer some
solutions to this because I believe the
free market can handle all of this stuff
because in government run and government
funded buildings there should always be
a third space for us to use and I do
when I go to the capital and stuff like
that I always use third spaces but I
think that private property owners can
make the rules for their establishment
and figure out how to enforce those
rules mean I wouldn't say SP for Trans
exctly we're in a state right now we're
in a state right now where you have to
allow anybody to use whatever restroom
they want if you're a decent human being
you do what causes the least disturbance
so for example I filmed a YouTube video
uh a few years ago where I entered a
men's restroom just because I was just
wanting to comment to her like well
maybe you should use a men's restroom if
you really feel like the way you feel
and I said okay let's do it let's put a
camera and I was kicked out within
seconds of the entire establishment and
it was a whole Ruckus so that's what I I
mean by if you're a decent person you do
what causes the least amount of problems
for people around you and if you're you
know a moral person you're going to be
conflict avoidant in general when it's
something like that right it's like
what's the point of causing issues for
anyone especially if you're really just
trying to pee I just put down go in and
get out right can the disagreer please
step
forward I want to comment on Blair's
point the one thing I kept hearing
through all of the Nuance is passibility
and ultimately ultimately when we talk
about passibility it determines how you
get harassed in the bathroom because
honestly if you don't look so passible
or whatnot people are going to say oh
that's a man with a dress on and then
there's going to be discourse but the
reality of it is honestly who cares
who's trans and who SS going in the
bathroom you should be minding your own
business being able to pee and do with
your business in peace for the most part
that com that um conversation around
this man with a boner on or whatever
like that I saw that picture and I
thought to myself that's really a
right-wing talking point and
conservative propaganda because that's
their ideology when it comes to trans
I'm speaking that's their ideology when
it comes to transits because trans I'm
sorry conservatives have a basic level
understanding of what transness is in
the first place and with all due respect
I do not think any of you are basic but
they use you as the Baseline
to amplifying this propaganda how is it
propaganda if it's a thing that really
happened it was caught on video like it
was an actual occurrence it wasn't
staged it it happened and that's not the
it's an isolated in Incident That's not
enough for me to say because actors can
do that who knows they could have been
an actor trying to make a point against
trans people but this has always been
our battle it's just like from what I
just heard you were saying with your
talking fors CU I did understand what
you were saying I just got the word
passibility out of there and which
didn't say that word at all no I'm
saying that he said passibility she
didn't say it he did and the problem the
okay I didn't I can he I just couldn't
hear back there the Liberals always use
them yeah no what I'm saying is I'm not
saying you said that word what I was
getting out of what you were saying the
one word that was coming to me was
passibility this is Blossom saying it
and so passibility is passibility
politics is really a thing in our trans
Community especially when we come to the
debate of restrooms well you can say
it's politics but actually it's just
real life right it's just about where
you're able to assimilate to and where
you're not and I think one of the
biggest problems in the trans Community
is the community by and large has seemed
to reject assimilation and seems
hellbent on that's not true I think it's
absolutely true which is you see people
talking about how you don't need to work
on your transition at all to enter
women's restrooms and I think that that
is so selfish so it's so disregarding of
women who may or may not feel
uncomfortable the transwoman experience
is not monolithic so who are
Poli trans why are we policing other
people's trans how they show we have to
to protect why are y'all policing though
that's what I don't understand you're
using words that we're not using it's
not policing we're listening to women
and if you have 50% we won't say 50% but
if you have a large chunk of the
population of women saying that they are
uncomfortable with a certain thing a
good person leans in and listens they
don't just re other trans women Blair I
think do all day am right now but you
didn't but you didn't and and I'm not
I'm not trying to be combative or
whatever like I'm just trying to figure
out you know what I'm saying what the
middle ground would be between you and I
because you you said one side and that's
great but what about the side of trans
women if we're not bringing both sides
into this conversation then it is
unbalanced here's what I would say then
because I do understand both sides I
didn't you know I'm almost a decade in
my transition which means I was one time
a year in 6 months in two months in so I
understand that but I also knew at the
very beginning of my transition that if
I'm not at a place physically where I'm
not making people feel UNC or I'm making
people uncomfortable then that's on me
that's my responsibility to make sure
that I'm going places a certain way to
make sure that they're comfortable
because it's for your sa also too right
would you also say that you're safe your
safy plays a part that you seem to be
looking at through the lens of always
trans being the priority and I'm looking
at through the lens of women being the
priority here um there's plenty of
situations why why I just want to know
why because it's them who would fall
victim to not actual trans women as I
said but people posing as trans women
people who are trans women are also
victims of that as well I'm sorry I
would love it if the two of you have
said your piece and I would love to hear
everybody yeah I just want to make this
point I just want to make this point as
well but trans women also experience
violence and also need that protection
and so that's the thing like it should
be an even playing field I'm not saying
you're wrong but what I'm saying is I
would like to challenge you to expand to
make sure you're being inclusive of both
sides or whatever because we got to have
we have to have these important
conversations between CIS women and
trans women and I'm just going to say
and I'm not going to just say CIS wi I'm
going to say women biological women I
want to make it inclusive of everyone I
think the middle ground though is and I
feel like I'm not coming at this from an
extreme place I feel like an extreme
place would be like no trans wom in the
bathroom ever that's the extreme
position I'm saying work on your
transition take it as your
responsibility and be respectful and
that's the middle ground right this this
is a this is this is a self-preservation
issue right so if somebody's in the
bathroom and they have a boner that
looks bad on all of us and when people
and when our community is not calling
that out and not saying that this is
wrong how many how many I'm just to your
point how many cases has that occurred
it happens it happens a lot we see it's
happening all the
time twitters I'm sorry like I just want
to make the sure the back and forth goes
everywhere I mean there's Twitter
accounts with millions of followers that
show this stuff multiple times day and
and so we're we're showing that the
these types of things do actually cause
harm to trans people so if you're
looking at it trans lens and to say what
what are we doing we need to combat that
stuff and come together to combat that
stuff it does not Encompass the entire
trans experience and that's all I just
want to say yeah I think I see a lot of
different points from everybody here
honestly like I can understand like how
some women may feel unsafe with men and
there in the restroom men when I say men
I mean men I'm not talking about trans
women so being a non-binary person that
sometimes has the choice to either going
into a men's restroom looking like
this looking like this you can look at
me looking like this it's just
interesting I thought this was a trans
debate that's what I
thought no they don't yeah so I don't
know maybe you could educate yourself a
little bit on that maybe then you figure
out you what reality is what non-binary
Jubilee
episode W well because it's is not a
debate about who is really trans and who
is not we're talking about restrooms as
a trans non-binary person when I go into
a place that only has men men's and
women's restrooms and I'm dressed like
this MH my choice of going to the men's
restroom at that point puts me in danger
6 years ago when I I've transitioned
almost eight years ago but six years ago
it was never an issue for me to use the
women's room girls would literally drag
me in there with them and said girl you
need to be in our bathroom and I was
like uh I felt uncomfortable back then I
don't pass I know I don't pass so that's
a me problem and I'm not going to turn
my fear of being attacked in the men's
room into a woman's problem it's still a
me problem so I need to work on myself
and and it it sucks does it suck yes it
sucks I don't pass I know I don't pass
but I still respect women enough and I'm
some PE some trans people aren't capable
of handling themselves against a man but
I'm confident in my ability to do that
and not everybody can I I get that but
it's just now six years ago I used to
use women's room now I don't because
women have spoke out they've come out
and said we're not comfortable there's
too many self ided people out there just
taking advantage and I I choose to use
the men's room to protect them I can
definitely actually uh almost empathize
with a lot of trans women in their
experience in the bathroom and a lot of
the uh turmoil with going in and uh you
know especially with passibility but the
the layer that I feel like in the
conversation that's missing here is
actually trans men and also the fact
that I was born biologically female and
a lot of the things that trans women
experience of violence in the bathroom
is what I experienced as a child so the
reason why my education here is not
necessarily to create uh an idea that I
need to conform to eurocentric standards
myself I'm a six foot tall transman size
13 shoe so I don't fit into the
eurocentric standards of what a woman is
and I never did as a child I was uh you
know bullied relentlessly for this and
isolated from many spaces so this
discussion about trans women being in
the restroom also affects biological
women because here's guess what you know
biological women come in all shapes and
sizes there are you know a lot of
lesbian women that deal with this issue
that I've related with and and and and
empathized because we both get pulled
out of the restroom and thrown and and
and guys try to beat us up because we're
in a restroom with women and then on top
of it to add that layer that it's not
even being discussed in any mainstream
that this is just completely wiped out
and that you're standing up for women
but you're not standing up for women
children you're not standing up for
biological females that are children
you're only standing up for what really
affects you and it's kind of sad that
the idea that passibility is is you need
to work on your transition a lot of
folks especially in our community have
no access to finances resources jobs to
even get their foot in the door to get
access to hormones so you're putting all
of these barriers just for them to be
able to go to the restroom which is a
natural thing that we all have to do so
what do I need to do piss outside
because that's how I was treated my
entire childhood that would I just feel
like when this whole topic comes up like
it obviously goes back to like there's
dudes like jerk off in the bathroom and
like to me like when I hear that I'm
like okay like but that's not trans
women so when we talk about this
conversation and it seems like the fear
is like literally cisgender straight men
who are being creeps and what sucks is
CIS straight men can be like creepy and
then it's like trans women trans men are
like paying the price for that and I
feel like you know what that's what's
really hard about it is because then I
think people get the idea or some people
have the belief trans women are just
like they're just men and dresses you
know what I mean but but at the end of
the day like for so many trans women and
so many trans men the safest place for
them is the bathroom that aligns with
their gender and if you go to a place
where it's illegal to do that or you
have to go and like what's your ID or
like your birth certificate it puts you
in an objectively unsafe situation and
for me like I'm like if I walk in the
women's room I mean I know I like look
like a I look 12 but like I feel like
someone be like get out of here you know
what I mean but like that's the vibe
like I think you got to remember like
when we're talking about it and we're
talking about like these creepy dudes
like in the bathroom here's the middle
ground here's the middle ground you got
youall ready we're going to be so happy
with this this is the middle ground we
all actually agree it's men that are the
problem it's not trans women real trans
women however the problem is our
community has really eroded any barriers
to actually being Trans in the sense of
your average crossdresser can identify
as a trans woman but then it's not a
trans woman well you I'm glad you feel
that way I feel that way as well I agree
with you wholeheartedly however with the
of the political correctness within the
trans Community you can't really say
that like that
person they say that they're trans I
actually do agree with you Blair 100%
because that's one of those things yeah
I told you I'm really like that God and
the reason why I say that is because
sometimes when we self-identify some
people can take advantage of that and
that is something unfortunately that we
cannot control but we have to combat it
combat it with facts with research and
with the information that is presented
in front of us it seems like we're the
ones that's teaching everybody else
because we live in a predominant CIS
World we're teaching them about us and I
just really think we cannot afford to be
intellectually dishonest about our
experiences as trans people there is
something that I think we can do there's
solutions to this like I I do think that
something like you have to be on
hormones or something like that for two
years or something before you can even
change your ID like an across the board
that would eliminate the crossdressers
from being able to go there because then
you can say hey my ID says this and you
and and so it shows that you've actually
taken steps it doesn't it's not about
passibility it's about how long you've
actually been taking the steps to
transition I support the transgender
military ban agre
years I think that often times when you
talk about trans people in the military
people forget that most places if we're
talking about feet on the ground and
really going into war zones are really
dangerous for Trans people and so it's a
really an extra risk you're talking
about the culture that exists over yeah
the Middle East you know it's like
that's not exactly trans friendly it's
actually the opposite the medications
that we take sometimes put us in
conflict with being able to actually be
combat ready uh but there is some Nuance
here obviously like if there was a trans
cook or a trans medic I'm not exactly
going to be upset but um for the most
part when it comes to combat I hate
supporting like what you just said I
hate supporting it because it goes to
The Narrative of the um should athletes
compete in sports you know but trans
athletes yeah the the drugs we take do
weaken us you know so we're not like you
just said comeback ready but we're also
not as physically strong as the guy
counterparts standing right next to us
and I will say like as a person with HIV
I was diagnosed at 18 um I couldn't go
into the military like because I
couldn't get big tarv overseas you know
yeah so I I will say as probably the
only person that served in the military
on this entire panel you should spoke
first um it's okay um the thing about it
is I think there there is a lot of
nuance in this I actually have friends
that are currently serving in the
military I think there was a lot of um
miscommunication of what the trans ban
actually did you know you have soldiers
if you have surgeries they go on profile
which means they can't actually do their
job they they can't do pt um if you have
bottom surgery it it takes a year and so
as a leader that person's fill in a
position of a job of somebody that
should be doing it um I don't mind
somebody who is actually on hormones
going there because there's a lot of
people I mean people take ptsv
medications overseas they actually take
six months of medication with them um so
a full out ban I don't necessarily
support um because I think that any and
everybody in the the military as long as
you can do your job you can go in there
and nobody really cares but it is those
times when if you can't perform your job
that that becomes an issue um you talk
about with HIV actually most people
don't even realize this if you contract
HIV while you're in you can stay in a
non- employable job right and then also
you know if we want to just get super
real you have the trans suicide rate and
if you really want to compound that by
the veteran suicide rate that's not
exactly concoction for very positive
results so I see how a trans band could
actually benefit us and Lord knows I'm
not trying to get drafted SOI I'm I'm
I'm all good with that
period I think it's very discriminatory
to keep trans people out of the military
we pay our bills here we pay our taxes
here we are Americans we deserve to
serve this country as well however you
all did raised some great points about
the concern and safety of trans people
and I do agree that something does need
to be done about that to protect us
who's protecting us in the
military who is I mean if you're even
diagnosed with like mild social anxiety
you're not eligible to enter the
military if you have like a crooked left
you know pinky toe you're not eligible
so discriminatory I mean that word
sounds pretty in today's climate very
much like oh no discrimination but it's
not always bad sometimes for the safety
and it's like you know when it comes to
the military and when it comes to
keeping America safe that has priority
or anyone's feelings discrimination is
discrimination and I don't think there's
way around it it's still discrimination
me it's netive though our troops over
there while they're over there you're
talking or protect them before so they
can get in both it is important to
protect all trans people in the military
well we can't waste resources way to
protect them is not putting them in the
Middle East with Muslims they going to
kill them well I just want to interject
your point about suicide so it's
somebody who has worked uh in community
service with uh community members
directly a lot of their suicide issues
actually revolve around access to
finances and the military is one of the
highest employers of transgender people
so we actually see the suicide rate drop
and for me personally but it's one of
the highest employers of anybody but if
you're suicidal and you go into a job
that has a high likelihood of PTSD
causing PTSD and all these other issues
then it becomes a big issue because then
you already have a one mental illness
then you're compounding it with more and
when you're on you know a very strict
regimen of if you know if you're trans
and if you're really trans and we can
get into who's really trans later
because I say about that if you're going
to be on hormones right you're not
always going to have access to those
drugs when you're deployed and when
you're in those situation that's why I
say if you're you know a line cook or
something if you're whatever that's one
thing but if we're talking about combat
you're not exactly going to have access
to your testosterone blockers and your
how do you how do you know that because
Medical
medical is covered in the military so
they should have access to that so that
is false information you guys are foret
the fact well hold on you guys have all
forgotten the fact of what is the flip
side for these transgender individuals
that are signing up for the military and
they're taking out and that was their
life plan where are they supposed to
work and where is their employment
supposed to be because the mental
illness that happens through
homelessness and the lack of resources
that so that is also the flip side of
that so if folks don't have hold on one
second but if they don't have access to
a job that could aler them
and research and access to medication
access to benefits lifetime benefits
that's something that most transgender
people in any sector of any job you want
an answer to your question or are you
just going to round because I can answer
you said what about those people that
were kicked out I actually think it's
bad if you are someone who was in it and
you really are because just like you
know Sarah and I've met many trans
veterans that I've paid respect to
publicly on social media and I think
it's amazing actually so if you're
kicked out and it was once you know the
norm resources you're I'm speaking
though if you're kicked out and you it
once was the norm for you to participate
in the military that's sad but at the
same time if that is what is determined
for the ultimate safety and
effectiveness of the military nothing
should come before that Blair have you
ever the second bomb have you ever
worked directly am right now I am right
now services in terms of nonprofits and
actually getting client she's notti she
is not a Grassroots person because truth
be told a lot of our community is in
Grassroots
just hold on just a second took care
their bills offing them Services getting
through a lot of trans trans
organizations that are ran by trans
people I really want to see what you've
done for those organizations cuz I don't
see any of y'all on the front line I'm
on the the front line like what are you
talking about I've dedicated hold on
hold on I've dedicated my entire life to
in my own way and you can disagree with
it because we all have our vehicles and
our methods towards promoting trans
acceptance and the ultimate progression
of the quality of life of trans people
I've dedicated my entire life to that
right I access millions of people every
single month on all my social media and
I have people reaching out all the time
saying that I've saved them from just
like we mention suici
physically have you ever taken
on someone
you you guys you you guys are asking
questions and you have no interest in
the answer I'm sure you guys are very
very proud of the fact C player that's
what we're saying how could it be a
circle when I haven't answered the
question at all because you keep
speaking I'm sure you guys are very
proud that you can enter a building and
work with 25 people at a time I access
Millions every month not what is it you
know it's really disappointing that you
would
ever disconnected this is disappointing
actually this is very dis it's
disappointing that you would disrespect
all of the people that are in community
service and all of these social workers
that actually do help trans people and
it's really disappointing that you guys
are disrespecting what the [__] I do
right when you say something about what
is Grassroots that's the problem that I
feel that some trans disconnected not a
that is a tangible resource organization
because if you this is where y'all's
privilege come in because if y'all don't
need Services my content is a resource
if you do not need services from non
that are transl you I was rais by drug
addicts I have iate resour rather create
res
so we're going to work with d
transitioners who actually need our
help but we're not talking about mil oh
my God another one but I'm going to give
you one more chance it's the
condescension for me you know I will let
I will take a step back and let other
people have an I feel like the I feel
like so like Blair said like when you
want to go into the military like they
got to like check you out and like are
you fit to go into the military whatever
for that reason I don't feel like a like
a ban on trans people in the military is
necessary cuz I feel like who's ready to
to go to combat and who's ready to go in
like they'll get in I think there are
people who are like able to do that
maybe people who aren't and I feel like
that will be determined without just a
ban across the board and yeah so it
wasn't actually a full ban though that's
what people don't realize okay so you
can still enlist nobody got kicked out
of the military they didn't kick a
single person out of the military who
who came forward and had gender
dysphoria two it was actually easy it's
more open to serve under the the ban
than it was under don't ask don't tell
yeah okay so you could actually be a
trans person and present however you
wanted off duty you could go to a ball
in a dress and nobody cared and you
couldn't they couldn't kick you out and
serving in the military it's not a right
they can disqualify you for any reason
physical anything people get kicked out
all the time because they can't pass PT
test right and and overseas yeah you
don't necessarily have access to
refrigerators for your testosterone or
any of that other stuff so if you're
taking injections it's a lot different
I'm supposed to refrigerate it I don't
know I don't take T in the midle
hor is going to Beale hormones are not
always refrigerated let's just make that
clear well my concern would be that like
who's joining the military not to serve
in the country but only to get the
cheaper drugs and the paid for surgery
and I don't want that trans
person join the military because they
got a woman pregnant and they just need
to pay their bills there's so many re
because I want dedicated want dedicated
people that want to defend the country
that live in there are easier ways to
get drugs there are easier ways to get
drugs and to join the military that's a
big commitment to get drug just put it
this way there are far less debilitating
things that will disqualify you from
access to the military than trans and if
you want to put it on a scale trans is
one of those things that for a lot of
people is quite debilitating whether
it's mentally physically whatever if you
have you know social anxiety if you have
depression any of these things that are
less mentally taxing than gender
dysphoria all those things
then why is it that we should have like
aound because we're trans I go with what
the generals say I go with what the
people at the top say this is what is
the most effective way to have our
military just not General M I just
really hope that the people you I me
that I just really hope that the people
at the top that you're referring to
aren't transphobic because let's be
clear of the isms that are in the
military ex me I'm speaking do not
interrupt a black transform when she's
speaking you interrup when it comes to
did the
interruptor if you are black and trans
and you want to go into the military I
am quite sure that my experience would
not look the same as y'all's and if we
can't wake that up then we're really
being complic I don't think your skin
tone makes any
difference for you to tell a black
person that is so for you to tell a
person because I am this is my
experience and this is my reality first
of all that is so disrespectful to tell
a person
black how they should feel how dare you
sit
up you wanted me here and I'm here so
what you going do you wanted me here so
I'm here you particular
calm what are you talking about it's not
my fault that y don't understand respect
sorry let's pause interrup my can you
please stop stop stop we're good you
need to calm down you do honey rul my
God someone get a Xanax for her oh keep
your keep it cute girl keep it real cute
body
the the rules are you cannot speak when
somebody else is speaking Fair
okay you haven't found a middle ground
that's okay I think we did okay I feel
like I feel there's a little bit mixed
in there yeah I agree with what y'all
were saying it wasn't really like I
thought it was great so imagine when we
disagree that'll be fun I feel like it
was really interesting hearing your
perspective about being in the military
and I don't know if there's really like
a true Middle Ground found but I feel
like I have like a better understanding
of kind of where you're coming from with
it and I feel like a lot of points make
sense and it's also an issue that is
hard to get a definitive answer and
agreement on everybody doesn't have the
same struggle and that does include in
the military people some people in our
community have to go through much more
extremes than others and so for me my
question
becomes how are they being taken care of
especially when a trans person comes out
in the military yeah we have these
things enacted but that doesn't mean
that in reality and in physical time
that they're being treated under what is
under what is in the law that's supposed
to protect them so that's where I'm
coming from or whatever because reality
and what's on paper are two different
things but they are so this is again the
culture of the military this is this is
a debate that we have as civilians that
the military doesn't have okay just
plain and simple if you can do your job
nobody cares who you are what you do
what what your
extracurricular activities outside of
the military are all they care is that
they can count on the person to the left
and right of them and again like I said
before in the very beginning if you
can't deploy and you can't go do your
job then there's really not a big reason
for you to be there and to agree with
your point I'm not in the military nor
am my military General but I trust that
military generals know how to get their
troops deployment ready and if someone
is able to go through all the rigorous
steps take out the trans but they've
been able to meet Medical Health all of
the the the Hoops that need to be met I
don't see any reason to take away
someone's opportunity to serve this
country and to be proud of serving this
country because being American is
something to be proud of yeah and like
the the the trans band didn't actually
do that like I said before you you just
couldn't go like actually like take
hormones and transition while you were
in and it was a lot different cuz I
served in 2010 2011 before don't ask
don't tell was repealed so I know what
it was like before that as well and I I
totally agree with what you're saying so
I there's some that ground Let's go
people go my ha schools should include
transc conversation in sex ed join our
middleground patreon to watch this
exclusive
prompt it's okay for miners to get Top
surgery really you guys waited on that
that's pretty vile I feel like um the
vibe is like I I like as someone who had
Top surgery and went on hormones like
it's a very emotionally intense
experience I think in terms of like
miners getting surgery like the reason
why I'm not like no to that is because I
feel like maybe someone's like 17 or
something I honestly feel like it is a
really intense surgery but I feel like
if somebody's like 17 or like late 16
and like feels like it's right for them
I mean like people are really different
I know for me like Top surgery when I
was like 16 would have been like so good
and it would have literally like saved
my spinal cord from like binding all the
time that's why I'm like yeah like I
feel like in instances like it can make
sense so I'm not a trans man so I don't
have the experience or whatnot but I do
think that it has to be done safely
there is a process when it comes to
having these types of gender affirming
surgeries you know what I'm saying
talking with your parents and then going
to endocrinologists and going through
therapy to make sure this is right for
you people have a choice to their
autonomy now I know that everybody does
not but those that do or what not should
choose with the Right medical education
yeah they should choose with um safety
and with full understanding of what is
um a benefit and what may not be a
benefit I agree with a caveat that there
does need to be some sort of process
which there is by the way in place yes
abut um sometimes does it slip through
yes things happen because again as I
said earlier this is a big world but to
again negate people the ability to walk
through a door that you have walked
through I'm going to say this again and
then close it behind you is a little bit
of a slap in the face for anybody who's
seeking transition yeah and as somebody
who has experienced uh Top surgery and
also waited quite a bit of time a lot of
severe damage actually was created to my
rib cage that my wife who is half my
size actually has the same size uh rib
cage in the back as mine um and these
are permanent damage to my body because
I B I binded for about eight years and
there's even still issues that I have
with breathing and certain issues that I
face that um you know unfortunately if I
had that surgery a lot ear earlier I
would have a better posture I'd have a
lot of pain that is not within my body
that I have to deal with on a daily
basis while uh simultaneously the idea
idea that you
know I get maybe under 16 Top surgery
would be something that would possibly
even make me a little uncomfortable but
I also know that I was homeless at 16
paying my own rent and uh left my home
at 16 and had to live my life as an
adult very early so I was able to make
those decisions for myself but I think
it's weird that others can't seem to see
that I could make a medical decision for
myself when I had to physically take
care of myself and I look at of these
younger kids and there's a sense of
jealousy there and excitement for them
at the same time because they now have
access to memories and being in the
space and being in a comfortable body
that you know I had a lot of isolation
growing up in my childhood because I
didn't feel comfortable to present in a
female space or a male space I was
isolated constantly from school from the
outside world from my family and my
transition my top surgery has done
nothing but take physical pain off my
body especially with as large as chested
as I was and having to bind for as many
years as I
did I don't think any Miner should be
having life altering elective surgery or
life altering elective medicalization uh
period um and so I when I work on bills
across the country that that do ban this
for minors there's a couple things I
point out um I point out that I don't
think a 16-year-old female who wants
breast implants should be able to get
that either when we look at what we
allow miners to do like surgeries and
stuff like that they're not life-saving
they're not if you don't get it you're
not going to die it's not like getting
you like having an appendicitis and
having to get your appendix removed or
anything like that it's elective I think
that's the key Point here agree my thing
about surgery I'm actually vly against
surgery like all of it Top surgery
bottom surgery all of it UMC
particularly because you need your
genitals like it's just that simple you
know you you have these people now who
have nonfunctioning fake penises and
vaginas that you know they you've had
issues like for instance Richie had
where like your urethra folds in half
and then you can't pee no more this is
about are you against Top surgery too
yeah yeah I mean just or just surgery in
general I don't think that that's
necessarily like like you said it's not
like you have a pentis it's not like
you've got like a bone spur it's you
know like you don't I disagree with that
because I was in physical pain and
moment that I got that Top surgery the
pain was was that's not that's that
that's need that means you need a breast
reduction my friend no it's just binding
dud binding goes crazy I mean I binded
it for eight years I know like it sucks
but like if you just keep binding like
honestly like my ribs are like I'm like
ew I hate my ribs like they're all like
messed up is that an issue with safety
of binding though I I'm actually
curious the thing is I think it comes
with like the size of your chest so like
I had a big chest so like I I had like I
had it was the only way you know what I
mean and I did try and like buy like
safely and I did buy like reputable like
binder Brands but it is a lot when
you're doing it for a really long time
and three days straight I know me too
like and that's what it's like you're
not supposed to was your doctor telling
you that that's not safe because you're
not even supposed to 24 hours myct old
school yeah but you know and I did have
to go through like very for Top surgery
and testosterone like I had to go
through like a really big process and I
think that's my thing is like instead of
an age thing I think there's like a pro
like there should be a process you
should have to like live as that gender
and be seeking care and be having like a
therapist for long term and a
psychiatrist for long term and an
endocrinologist for long term and like
it's really like specific to the person
and I think would be like really rare
anyway but that's just my stance that I
agree with to an extent this is
definitely the prompt that I am the most
passionate about because I think there
are few things more vile more
irresponsible
more you know
dangerous than saying a child can
consent to permanently removing a body
part that serves an extremely important
function D transitioners all over the
country can never breastfeed their
children if they can even have them
because if they did other things that
can stop them from having kids at all
right the idea that child can consent to
a sex change to gender affirming
surgery if you believe that there's
really nothing that you can believe they
can't consent to right because that's
pretty extreme that's permanent body
modification under the best
circumstances so you want to move aside
all the complications all the things you
can't do the sterilization not being
able to feed your kids you can even set
that aside just the permanent body
modification I mean you have to be so
demented to believe that a child fully
understands I heard a few conversations
about well if the child fully
understands they don't they don't
because they're
children 17y old like if a 17-year-old
is like living as male for like five
years the pr was about Miners and 12y
olds are getting Top surgery so it's
easy to say well if it's 17y olds okay
well in my state that's actually there's
a Nuance conversation about even 17y
olds I guess because the age of consent
in some places is lower but that's not
what's happening right it's 12-year-olds
when we talk about minors it's like what
age range are we really talking about
here because the because the thing is
when we talk about D transitioners or
whatnot all I hear is a lot of regret
right regret that they got these
surgeries regret of the compli
complications regret regret regret and
that's fine I'm not taking away
anybody's experience because these
things do happen but let's also remember
again there is a process now I have a
lot of empathy for those D transitioners
that have gone through the process and
they are suffering I do have people it's
not just that's where I'm that's where
I'm just talking about in the
conversation for this particular
conversation and I understand what
you're saying cuz you're absolutely
right there are more people young adults
we all do different things in our
transition some of us want bottom some
of us don't some want top some of us
don't so you need a lot of time as an
adult to figure out what you want to do
but see the thing is though some adults
don't even understand what they want to
do so kind how can a child see a
children wait a minute let's not let's
not underestimate the power of these
kids today okay they are very much
educated because they have much more
resources and access than we did coming
up so let's be very clear about that and
when we talk about transitioners that
has been the main topic here or what not
cuz I want we want to bring the
transitioners in to the room so there's
a space got your point I would like to
everybody else um to to your point about
the reason why I'm against it is because
like you said the children need to go
through the proper steps the parents the
doctors but in the state of
California if you as a parent tell your
minor no you're not getting this I'm not
affirming your gender I'm taking your
kids away and the California is going to
raise your kids for you so how's that
Canada that's not right we also know
that like all those safeguards that
you're talking about they're not
happening yeah that's what I'm
California will we know we know because
there was a whistleblower out of St
Louis and this isn't some conservative
whistleblower she was married to a trans
man and she considers herself queer so
she blew the whistle and said that they
had an in-house doctor if if if you
couldn't find a affirming um therapist
to sign off on the form they would they
would they would pencil they would
pencil whip it but do you believe that
it should happen do you believe there
should be a process when it comes to
medical transition there's no right
process for kids to hack off I was
asking herone I'm sorry I was asking
well I answered cuz I'm here in the room
so no okay thank you I feel like like
personally like if we're talking about
like a 12- getting Top surgery like to
me that's just like medical malpractice
because I know for me like to get Top
surgery like like I could only get at 18
cuz my insurance covered at 18 but I had
to start that process like long before
like even hormones was a long process so
I think there's like an area of literal
like medical malpractice because no like
kid at that age should be getting that
in my opinion because you do not know
but I do think there are instances where
like a 16 or 17year old like could get
it and I don't know if that means like
Banning like below 16 like whatever but
so in the UK um it was the um I can't
remember what it was it's the reason why
they're shutting down the Tavistock
clinic in the UK UK though is because
they found that when you start a child
on hormone or on py blockers than
hormones it leads it's basically a
foregone conclusion that they're going
to end up having surgery it puts them on
a path to um to sunk cost fallacy I I
just again I don't understand this
obsession with other people's others
people's children it's about caring
about kids I I'm talking oh my God it's
OBS together I have it
together stop yo the the obsession the
obsession with a conservative
about other people's kids if it is your
child it is your choice what you do with
your kid just to talk about someone
who's at 16 and the level of consent in
the state of California from my
understanding someone who's 16 can also
drop out of high school which would
severely affect their life and they have
access to that decision if they want to
because say they want to get at the job
market or whatever their ex you know
reason is but they have that option to
make that choice at 16 I will agree with
you that someone at 12 I'd be
uncomfortable with somebody at 12 years
old getting uh surgery um completely
because there's still a lot of the world
for them to learn about themselves uh
how to navigate it etc etc but for us to
have access to be able to drop out of
high school if we wanted to and make
such a lifechanging decision that could
affect I mean you economically uh
socially so many different ways but then
to say you know what you're not old
enough to make this DEC decision for me
again as somebody who was 16 and was in
such a religious family and all the
restrictions that I had if I didn't have
access to those things I don't know if I
would be here and I've learned a lot
through my transition and through my
access and I even grew up in the wild
wild west where everything was still on
YouTube and we didn't really even have
medical providers really even giving us
guidance and especially trans men so I
find it rather uncomfortable that we're
able to make a 16-year-old be able to
make that type of decision an
18-year-old is allowed to go into uh you
know service but for some reason we
can't give that same access to a kid to
have that Consciousness cuz I can tell
you at 16 I knew who I was I'm not at 12
not at 14 but 16 there's a certain level
of Consciousness and experience that
you've experienced in society that you
understand the pocket you fit in just
because other bad things happen doesn't
mean that that is okay it's like so just
because they can drop out of school
means they should be able to cut their
breast off
thank non-binary should not be
considered under the trans umbrella
let's go
girl this is evil I think that the
concept of a transgender
umbrella is inherently an issue right
because when you're talking about
something as nuanced complex um full of
social dynamics medical Dynamics so many
things to be considered when you're
talking about a transexual you should
really be specific right and this entire
concept actually of transgender is
relatively new like it came about in the
70s or through queer Theory when
originally it was about transsexuals
which was considered a medical diagnosis
which was a medical process and it's
defin something very specific so for me
when I hear that non-binary which if I'm
to understand correctly means think
androgynous right and it means you you
know identify somewhere in between male
and female um that's not what a
transexual is the definition of a trans
person is somebody whose body has been
altered or somebody who identifies as a
different gender whose body has been
altered by hormones or surgery and
there's two genders so if you want to
say you know you identify as a different
gender it had to be one of those two
which would make you a transexual if
you're actually trans I think it makes
about as much sense as saying that
bisexual is under the straight umbrella
it's like no that's a separate thing and
I think there's Beauty in being separate
things there's Beauty in having your own
lanes and my concern is there's so much
clearly as we see today um really heated
conversations about trans people that
when you start adding in queer Theory
nonbinary it just makes it muddy and the
people at home hello don't know what the
[__] you're talking about here's the
thing about a lot of the people who
identify as non-binary so to
speak when they do so they typically
don't medically transition and when you
do so that at that point it's a
costume well it's gender non-conformity
right and so
we this off I can't take this off yeah
as Blair's saying we look at gender
non-conformity which used to be okay you
can wear what you want you can you can
present however you want but it doesn't
make you something different you can't
you know as Blair was saying it it comes
out of queer Theory which is postmodern
neomarxism which means that there's no
such thing as absolute truth they don't
believe there's truth so it kind of
erodes the structure of society and and
it's actually really regressive in a lot
of ways because you end up getting it to
where it's literally based off of
stereotypes which we've tried to for so
long get rid of like it's okay to be
gender nonconforming male or gender
nonconforming female and and that didn't
make you non-binary it didn't make you
trans when I meet a trans person right
like a trans woman a trans man there is
an inherent camaraderie like when you
you know mentioned I can't take this off
part of me almost got a little bit
emotional I know it's hard to believe
people think I have emotions but I
really do and because I saw you in that
moment and I said you know what we are
similar in that way we may be different
in other ways we don't know each other
very well but we have that when I talk
to or I'm around a non-binary person it
doesn't really
you know click it doesn't connect
because it is so different so I think
that's inherently I should be able to
see some semblance of my own issue
within that person and I don't when
they're non-binary at all and so I have
no issue with non-binary people I just
don't think that we're the same and so
when when like I was saying before like
when our acceptance rate has completely
been destroyed because these people are
initiating violence in our name they're
going to self ID out of the category and
then we're going to be the ones left
holding the bag yeah it's just if sex is
a binary and you're neither of those
then you're not trans
hello I think it would be really hard
for a CIS person to truly imagine what
it's like to be trans and what it's like
to live with that and be born that way
and I'm not non-binary and so I really
cannot picture what it would I'm a
binary trans person I can't imagine what
it's like to be in between that but just
like how this CIS person can't really
truly understand that it doesn't mean
that it's not a thing and it's not real
and and I really believe that we have
like 85 years like on this Earth and
like so many people spend so much time
being like sad and uncomfortable in
their bodies and if we were just all
comfortable like if somebody like wants
to go by a name and like dress a certain
way and they are saying this makes me so
comfortable this is what makes me happy
there is no reason they shouldn't do
that and my God there is no reason why
we should say well you're not a part of
this cuz like this is us and like this
is whatever because literally like we
could all sit here and agree that like
non-binary people are like not a part of
the trans Community or whatever which is
not my opinion but we could like that
doesn't like change anything like
there's a whole we have a vast community
and I believe that nonbing people are a
part of the community cuz I have so many
shared experiences with so many
non-binary people I know we have very
similar experiences in growing up with
dysphoria with transition with anything
and nobody has to do anything nobody has
to transition in a way they don't want
to transition and yeah like let's be a
happy family my god let's all just be
happy that's my vibe yeah or fight the
fight together yeah like let's do it we
have separate fights though
it we're weakening our borders by
creating this divide within our own
Community this is so silly look I
actually understand like a lot of the
points that are being made here from the
conservative side because I grew up
conservative I voted when I was 18 I
voted for [__] Bush y girl like I was
conservative conservative okay so we're
the same age so it was not until my
later age that I kind of decided like
you know what let me be more open to
different types of communication
different types of people I actually
talked so much [__] about pronouns like
uh they them all this I was like what is
this trash when it first started really
coming out I did not disagree I did not
agree with it I was like what is this
this is stupid how can you be a them
blah blah blah blah I did the whole
thing the
grammatically you're interrupting me but
you were correct I'm I'm agreeing with
you they asked you not to comment and
you're commenting so if you could stop
that would be great thank you so anyway
as I was
saying um you know so I I changed my
mind because I got to spend time around
other people who were non-binary who
were non-conforming and I got to speak
with them and I got to experience their
life and their experiences and then I
realized myself I'm like [__] maybe this
is what I've been experiencing my whole
life only because I was exposed to it if
I would have never been exposed to it I
would have never known that this could
have been my experience and I would have
lived the rest of my life as a different
person as somebody who I'm not and it's
funny that you keep talking that some
people keep talking about oh you need to
go through HRT you need to have
surgeries and order to be trans that is
all garbage another thing I never said
is just so crazy again you're still
interrupting me while I'm talking this
is a second time you're addressing me
this is the second time now if you can
claim someone said something they didn't
say they should be able to correct you
in the moment I do you feel good now
that you said what you needed to say I
feel fine wonderful I'm sitting pretty
I'm fine so I mean sometimes it's like
the power that needs to hold me back I
me you're appropriating a medical
condition that's what you're really
doing I exist I am proof that non-binary
people exist and that that it is a thing
and because I'm sitting right here in
front of all of you all of you I'm a
real person this is my experience just
as yours sorry is just as yours is a
trans experience that as a trans Woman
as a trans man or as whatever but I'm
not here to belittle your experience or
to tell you that you don't exist and
that's the difference between you and I
that you're trying to
cancel you and when I say you I'm
talking about conservatives and maybe it
is you you're part of the thing you're
part of the thing I get to because stop
addressing her just talk to everybody
but what is your dysphoria well there
was some things let you okay so another
complete I don't want to say the word
lie but I guess that's what it is about
what I've said here right I never said
you don't exist so we can add that to
the long list of things y'all have said
I've said that I didn't we know you
exist you're here you're not fictitious
right my point is you're different than
me and I don't even think you deny that
but yet when I say it it's an issue
right the same way that he said he can't
take that that off you can right it's
different at the very least it's
different and when we have a community
that there are so many categories demig
girl Demi boy Astros seexual all this
[__] but y'all can't fathom that maybe
that would be a different category than
what I am when we have such different as
you keep saying and everyone keeps
saying experiences it doesn't make sense
a bisexual is different than a gay man
can can I ask a question I just actually
want to ask your question what is your
dysphoria though because gender
dysphoria or sex dysphoria as I would
rather call it is a an uncomfortability
between my secondary sex characteristics
not just what I wear on a daily basis
because masculinity and femininity
doesn't have anything to do with being
trans but that's not true but that is
not true you can have dysphoria without
having to be dysphoric about your sex
Parts what is your Doria straight CIS
women have dysphoria about their breast
l and they get breast augmentation that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean that I'm
not dysphoric about certain things that
doesn't mean that and you don't know my
life you're not in my life you don't
know what I experience that the
different things that I experience
personally I cannot believe that I grew
up as you know this 5-year-old little
kid experiencing just C crippling gender
dysphoria like horrible thoughts
struggled so much my entire life to be
sitting in this room and you're
explaining to her what dysphoria is I
have my experience it doesn't mean that
have crippling you got a different
experience a different we all have a we
all different experience differ I know
but we're all both not different things
that's it it's that simple we don't
identify as our gender at Birth
obviously I'm not a non-binary person so
I can't speak for nonbinary people but I
can talk about what I've been taught by
non-binary people from what I understand
when it comes to some non-binary people
sometimes they have to go into the
gender binary for safety reason
depending on the environment that
they're in a non-binary person person
stepping into this world and dismissing
the gender Norms of what people think a
man and a woman is supposed to be like
is so powerful if you don't want to be
mutable to the times of the expansion of
the trans and nonbinary experience then
just say that I would rather you just
say that you are not willing to move
forward learn the new terminology learn
the new pronouns that come with the
Trans umbrella and the trans experience
for the most part and also it's I'm
sorry one more thing and also too there
are non-binary people who have different
sexual orientations let's also name that
too there are so many layers of nuance
that we could really get to when it
comes down to the root of what being
non-binary is what's the definition but
doesn't make them trans my big thing
when it comes to you know I agree with a
lot of the things that you just said i'
I actually love you I adore you oh thank
you right back at you but here's the
thing right that's not the prompt The
Prompt was is it different and it is
again when I go out I can't like take my
beard off girl it's not coming off right
you know I unfortunately you know as
much as I hate having tripal hair
despite being a guy you know like real
it like I can't go and reshape my body I
can't go and shave my Adam's Apple down
I've been on this since I was 15 what if
it had gone wrong so I have an
interesting experience with non-binary
myself um as someone who has Pres
presented as a
um binary trans man I also don't take
testosterone so for me um especially
throughout my
transition uh I took testosterone for a
short period of time uh just to get the
beard and the Aesthetics that I wanted
to in my transition once I reached those
goals I personally um didn't want to
lose my um access to being able to give
birth to a kid especially with being
with Haw wife for 17 years we've been
wanting to have kids so I wanted to you
know have a backup uterus so to speak
and in that process of doing that I've
discovered a lot about myself and my own
identity of what is a man and what is a
woman and for me um when I take a look
at the the the issue in the conversation
there's kind of two things happening
simultaneously our community is
infighting with each other instead of
looking outwardly at these structural
systems that are actually truly
affecting us with laws politics access
to Medical Care and Etc while
simultaneously we see that the idea of
fitting into the patriarchal structures
the misogyny everything that is kind of
placed in us I don't subscribe to that I
mean I all my life have been breaking
the rules of what a gender IDE ideology
is just by my pure existence I didn't
grow up with the idea of knowing what
trans was my entire life I discovered
that actually being homeless I didn't
discover that through some Collegiate uh
access to college or influence from
others there was no one around me that
knew or that I knew it was trans I
discovered that myself but as I've aged
in my transition because I've been trans
for damn near almost 20 years now I've
discovered my own fluidity in that area
because I actually enjoy my female side
too doctors are manipulating transed
care I think there's three types of
doctors out there I think there are the
ones who absolutely think that they're
doing this for the right reasons I think
that there are the ones who are
absolutely doing it for money like we
saw at Vanderbilt the do the people at
Vanderbilt literally said this is a huge
money maker and then I think that there
are I don't know if it's incompetence or
ineptitude because or laziness because
what we're seeing not just in the trans
Community we're seeing in society ssris
being pushed on on patients Mental
Health doctors are pushing so many
different uh drugs without getting to
the root issues see I have a interesting
perspective on this I've been out for 11
years this year been on testost since I
was 15 years old and even looking into
it I waltzed my little ass up into that
doctor's office and I left on
testosterone he gave me my first shot in
the doctor's office that day oh my gosh
I was 15 years old what if I what if I
had been
wrong what if I had been wrong it really
just is that simple I'm joining M cono
wow nice to see you cuz I think like
it's not I don't think it's like a huge
widespread issue but I think when we
have like a for-profit healthare system
it does happen like I feel like there
are do I I believe that people should be
evaluated and go through tests and like
for me getting on testosterone and
getting surgery was a massive process in
my life but I do think that it probably
happens just like you said like with
ssris and stuff like things are
overprescribed so I do think it's a
massive issue um I think that Society in
general as Sarah mentioned is over
medicalized right now we're in this
weird climate where there are entire
political movements behind if you do
where you don't have a vaccine you can't
enter this building if you do you can if
you do you know it's like crazy but you
know when it comes to the trans issue I
think just the fact that there were
really almost no d transitioners as
recent as like five six years ago um and
the fact that it exploded now shows that
it is a massive issue and you know I
think that I can reflect what you said I
was over 18 when I started my hormones
but I had a 20-minute appointment and
just like you I walked in and out with
an estrogen prescription insane I wasn't
tested for to see a therapist first I
had no letter and you were a child I was
a child and that is a very very one of
the most conservative states in the
country so if that's what's going on in
Georgia can imagine what's going on
everywhere else California hello yeah
when I went from my um initial
appointment I literally helped my doctor
find gender dysphoria on his chart and
market for me that's insane and I walked
out with my prescription that day I I I
I mean because I do a lot of work with
the D community and the problem is is I
actually don't really care too much
about you know if you are an adult and
you walk into a doctor's office and want
want estrogen and you walk out that's I
don't think that's an issue what is an
issue is when doctors are not giving all
the information when they're actually
telling you that this is what's right
for you and then it's not um they're
actually manipulating their patients
they're manipulating you know they say
if you don't do this you're going to
kill yourself and and all this stuff so
I would actually rather a doctor say I
have no idea what this is going to do to
you but it's your body your choice you
can do what you want and then leave you
on your way and and you can make that
decision right I think they're not
asking the patient why why do you feel
this way a simple question another
another thing I was never informed of
you know when I started my hormone
journey and now it seems you know like
common sense but I was you know 20 so
it's like you know even 20y olds can
have oversights um no one told me I had
to freeze my sperm that's crazy so I'm
into estrogen I reach the the point of
adulthood where you maybe meet a partner
where that might be something you want
to do and I learned that I can't and
it's simply because that doctor didn't
care to tell me and why who knows maybe
it was because of money it was easier
for him or better for him to get me in
and out get that money rather than maybe
a couple more appointments where I'm
having to figure out you know how to
freeze my sperm in the meantime but a
lot of these doctors are also activists
they also don't tell trans men that
they're going to go through menopause
right there's a lot of issues with trans
man Buck Angel talks about that he
almost died he's a friend of mine like
yeah
insane um so I actually almost walked up
first um because I do feel like the
system is like pretty broken and there's
not enough education medical system for
doctors to be prescribing all the things
that they do again discussing ssris like
I was a victim of that myself and so you
know I I empathize for those stories
I I understand that that does happen I'm
not negating that um but I think to
negate you know medical service to
somebody who needs it um who who it
might be life or death for um just
because you feel some type of way about
it isn't right like why do you care what
you know little Timothy or or or Sally
or doing or whatever like why do you
personally care what well Timothy and 8
and 12 okay sorry we're doing no
comments but we're not talking about
children seven or 12 and this doesn't
happen often has it happened yeah it has
because that's the thing it's it's a big
world like things happen all the time
things we can't even imagine happen it
just is a reality but again to walk
through a door and then close it for
other people to walk through that's kind
of messed up in my opinion so so to your
point for being able to receive uh
hormone therapy in the way that you did
um I had a similar experience I was able
to walk in and get access to hormones um
and that system was set up through
advocacy because of what a lot of
community folks are actually facing when
it comes to access to hormones access to
Medical Care access to all of these
things so a lot of these nonprofits
actually got rid of a lot of the red
tape because for some individuals like
myself who was actually homeless during
my transition process I would have never
been able to afford access or get
through all of those process now and I
admit that there is some medical
malpractice yes I myself um had issues
obtaining testosterone
consistently um uh you know for some
reason you know the script doesn't match
up or you got to get in contact with the
doctor and it was part of the reason why
I chose actually to go off testosterone
because I didn't like the idea of not
having constant access because I was
worried about the damage that it could
cause to my body and also because I
wanted to keep intact my Reproductive
Rights uh from what I have seen when it
comes to these d transitioners
from my understanding in terms of the
statistics trans people are 8% of the
population and then the D transitioners
are somewhere from 1 to 8% as well so
all of these laws that are coming in is
to affect the entire Community as abroad
while we're the percentages that we
affecting people is so small while
simultaneously if we looked at things
like in the past like HIV with things
like a drugs that were harming folks
those folks went through all of those
processes and learn learn the research
of what it was to properly take care of
HIV through that unfortunate horrible
horrific process I mean it was basically
chemo yeah I mean a was killing people
and they had no clue what we doing now
unfortunately because trans people have
not got access to Medical transition is
long and especially in the trans
masculine Community there's a lot of
research that has not been done so to a
degree yes we are guinea pigs in the
shot in the dark but just like in the
80s when a was being discovered or 90s
when it's being discovered the those
folks had to go through that process and
I was given informed consent and
understood that when I signed that we
just don't know because the studies
aren't there like you said right so the
problem is when you talk about like the
D transition rate what generally happens
is there's no followup the longest study
that's been done is 5 years out the uh
average D transition happens between
four and 10 years so we're not capturing
all of that plus if you haven't had your
primary sex organs removed you literally
stop you just stop taking hormon and
then you never go see your doctor again
and so they never follow up and you just
fall off the roles so they the the stats
on D transition is completely false so I
want to say something first of all I
want to empathize with everyone here
when it comes to Health Care system
because it's not always for us um I
don't think that doctors are
manipulating trans care I think they're
still learning about trans care and to
your point there is not a lot of
research cuz the research is still new
and freshh you know the transitioning is
a thing but truth be told
detransitioning is actually rare when it
comes to not just wanting to be trans
anymore now the underlying factors
within that is Health Care conditions um
which I actually heard um a trans man
who is famous talk about you know very
well I agree with what y'all were saying
because these issues are very very real
but also I think it's really because
doctors are still learning about our
experience so I just have to say um some
things that were brought up about
detransitioners which I found just a
little bit ironic right because for a
community that is 1% or less of the
general population we can never seem to
find it within ourselves to find empathy
for even if it is the 1% of our
community which is D transitioners and
for the horrific medical malpractice
abuse mental and spiritual turmoil they
go through it's like so we want the rest
of the world to say this 1% matters but
our 1% doesn't matter that's the first
thing the second thing is it's not as if
they
detransition
because of just like you said the
loosening of all the restrictions to get
on these drugs it's like that's not a
good thing gatekeeping is a good thing
like making sure the right people are
getting on these drugs so there aren't
regret cases there aren't botched cases
that's what we have to go towards
because right now we're going down the
slippery slope of anyone can get on it
every single person here I'm pretty sure
just stated that they went in and walked
out in an hour or less to get their
hormones and that's a huge problem
especially a child because of things
that have happened to me I can see a
future where transitioning for adults'
band like I can because of everything
that's going on with kids I I think most
of us are against a ban on stuff like
that obviously we're all sitting for a
reason I think I had the common ground
though because everybody here kind of
also admitted that we don't have the
research and so when we don't have the
research and and and I I'll tell you I
think that adults can do what they want
but I think we we don't push forward
with transitioning
children until we have the research we
do the research and this is actually
what JPC pushes as well jpec
organization they push to get more
research on it so we absolutely know
what this does because even the wpath
guidance the latest guidance from wpath
everything that it says even about
puberty blockers the next it says it
cites a study and then it says we don't
know to your point about gaining
research how do you expect the medical
community to gain access to research if
we're just preventing these folks to
actually go through any of the processes
to learn the scientific method of what
is happening uh just like it with a
drugs where we learned that that was
actually harming us and now we have
things like big tarby yeah so it's the
same way as we have with any research
you have a very select very heavy
gatekeeping crew that you're allowed to
you know create these studies around and
you need a good checklist to be like
these people show all the actual signs
of gender dysphoria they are having like
very strong distress you know and in
every state that's passed bans on um
access for minors also has Provisions
except for in the most extreme cases to
conduct studies on gender affirming
transition is suicide
prevention look at our unified front I
mean obvious it's a known thing that
trans youth are at greater risk of
suicide and just suicidal ideations
which are horrible and will plague you
and like ruin your life and make it
awful and so I know there are a lot of
kids in a lot of pain and growing up as
a trans kid I was in so much pain and I
feel like I could have been spared of a
lot of that and gotten to enjoy my life
a lot more if I had earlier access to
gender affirming care and even the
gender affirming care that I did receive
later in my life and I went on hormones
when I was like 16 and I got Top surgery
at 17 that completely changed my life in
the most dramatic way and so yeah I
think it is life-saving care and I think
a lot of trans people would agree I
agree as well too I think gender
dysphoria is a real thing and we all
deal with gender dysphoria differently
um I know for myself or whatnot there
were times I wanted to end it all and
for me I went to Desperate Measures to
align my body with how I feel on the
inside and for some of us especially
living in the South we don't always have
access to hormone care so some of us
have to go to the black market we have
to do things to our body to be able to
align us to where we are not willing to
commit suicide um I don't think gender I
don't think that's the only way I think
there are other ways as well too but
honestly sometimes people just want
somebody that cares that wants to listen
as part of the regimen to um being able
to um prevent suicide I've chosen to not
medically
transition in my bottom half let's put
it that way but and this is the first
time I'm actually saying this out loud
but I I am having facial femin an
surgery and that was an incredibly
ridiculously difficult Journey um even
as an adult um who has a really good job
and access to really great uh Health
Care um but I still had to go through so
many so many hoops and I was still
denied by insurance and in my own
personal life I've also struggled quite
a bit with mental health and um you know
a lot of that really relates to the
certain parts of my body like I always
hated my body when I was younger and I
didn't understand why and you know and I
was always dressing you know as like a
CIS male and I just had all this the
stuff just didn't fit it just didn't
feel right and it it was just like a
this darkness in my life like I just
wanted it you know gone um and I just
learned to live with it but then
eventually like you know After figuring
out who I am and and all that like now I
know like this is this is life saving
care like this for me is life saving
care like who knows where I could be in
in a few years had I not um known who I
am and had access to
care how y'all
doing I think too often we hear you know
that if we don't affirm our child's you
know gender identity that's different
than their their sex then they're going
to commit suicide we hear this all the
time especially from the D transition
Community whose parents were told this
and it was manipulative we hear
politicians say this all the time when
they're trying to you know stop bills or
pass bills the problem with that is
that's the same line that abusers use so
when you're in a relationship if you're
going to leave somebody and they say if
you leave me I'll kill myself then that
is an abusive situation and it's not you
know so that's the premise we start with
transition I mean we we're all here we
know transition is not an easy process
it takes a heavy mental toll and so I
really think that you have if you're if
you're already suicidal you have to get
that in check you have to be in a
healthy place before you can even think
about going through the medicalization
of transitioning you can socially
transition I think that's absolutely
fine but I think that you know before
you even think about medically
transitioning then I I think you have to
have your head right before that because
and hormones will make you feel kind of
crazy anyways so I think that that's why
yeah it's not
crazy see when it comes to gender
affirming care I appreciate everything
that gender affirming care has done for
me um and I I thank God every day that
this was the right decision for me
because I have friends like Richie who
it wasn't the right decision for and now
he's missing genitals so you know when
when it comes to it being lifesaving the
reason I didn't step forward even as
somebody who might agree with that
prompt is because correlation is not
causation what do you mean by that just
because something is related to another
thing does not mean it directly causes
it okay there's a little thing called a
self-fulfilling prophecy right and
sometimes when we create a narrative it
can kind of take on a life of its own so
I know there's a lot of talk about
suicide statistics in the trans
community and interestingly almost all
of those statistics come out of LGBT
activist organizations who have an
incentive to put those numbers out to
portray this image that we are suffering
greatly we're under attack and then all
of those suicide rates are due to
societal mistreatment and when these
kids are being told like you said when
they're going into these doctors the
doctors are telling their parents
essentially emotional blackmail they're
saying trans your kid or your kid's
going to die and they say it in front of
the child and they set up this false
dichotomy as if those are the only two
options moving forward and here to tell
any child feeling any type of way those
are not your only two options in fact
there is a vast array of options in
between and around suicide and
transition therapists and doctors aren't
even legally allowed to say no you're
not trans you're actually experiencing a
orc and that's the case with d people as
well they have this this huge host of
issues depression body dysmorphia
anorexia eeden disorders um maybe sexual
abuse in their past people don't know
that a symptom a long observed symptom
of sexual abuse is wanting to be the
other gender to cope with it so this has
been in textbooks forever so I just
think I'll wrap it up quickly I just
think it's a false dichotomy that it's
either death or transition um and but
with that said I agree with you I
appreciate everything that transition's
uh done for me but it's too much of a
role of the dice and I think it's
unhealthy telling people dud it or
you're going to die especially a child
so for the lgbtq organizations we also
have to remember that they are relying
on reputable resources and a lot of
those reputable resources are the
medical research that has been put out
there so all they can do is take that
information and be able to disseminate
that into the community to be quite
honest with hold on just second to be
quite honest with you and let's also be
clear that these researchers are also
collaborating with these organizations
because they are the ones that have the
most Outreach to the community that they
need to serve which is the trans
Community because often times the reason
why nonprofit grassroot organizations
are created in the first place is
because there was no place for us and so
it is really hard to get that research
to be able to do that we can agree to
disagree but the research has not been
compl completely fulfilled yet because a
lot of these people don't even know
about our experience and that is why
it's important that we make it very
clear what we need to do there's also
speaking of the numbers that come out of
LGBT act activist organizations there
was a little number that the life
expectancy of a transom was 35 that was
rescinded a couple years ago after like
over a decade of that being like just
factually you know shared and I always
thought that my life was statistically
going to end at 35 so but those numbers
were based on by those organizations
prostitute deaths so it's not always the
most reputable numbers they're getting
you know what I mean and these activist
organizations are political too we get
caught up in calling them activists and
we think it's this emotional spiritual
thing but they are political
organizations yeah so I am an activist
and so a lot of what you're talking
about really was focused more on black
Trans women because black Trans women do
not live past the age of 35 because
often times it is our group within the
trans community that is often murdered
we're often harassed we're often
discrimin at against and so a lot more
of that Focus has had to be around black
brown indigenous folks because often
times the research goes missing for us
they sourced it from prostitutes though
that was the source of the but see the
thing is though even when we talk about
prostitutes trans women have to
sometimes participate insect work to
survive but they based it off Cy
prostitutes sorry I'm done it was just
it was false number so from what I
understand is a lot of that Focus has
always been around black Trans women
because we do not get to see the age of
35 you were in a place when I I say
privilege you're in a place of privilege
where you do not have to worry about the
harassment and the Discrimination that I
face I face as a black person I faces a
black person I'm not going to say that
you do not experience harassment or
discrimination that's not what I'm
saying because like you said you're a
person of nuance and so follow me here
when I come as a person of color as a
black Trans woman you and I do not get
to have that same experience there are
more there are more rooms that you get
to walk in that I will be forbidden in
and one thing about it is that's why
it's important like someone like me has
to create her own space to be able to
counteract what you're doing and I'm not
saying and I'm not saying that you don't
but what I'm saying here is what I'm
trying to get you to understand is my
blackness should not have to pay for
your
whiteness that that does make sense is
destroying my community I'm destroying
your community you going to tell all of
my ex how you going to say that that's
the end what you're talking about too is
there's not the research you're right
there's not everybody likes to cite the
turban study and Jack turban is a
complete activist you can just go to his
Twitter account and see how actively
involved he is in this and how
financially what was his name Jack
turban okay and and you can see how much
he's financially gained off of this
study and the issue is the study is
based on a survey and so it's based on a
survey of adults and so when you're
doing a one surveys are not
scientifically accurate they're the
least accurate way to do it study and so
when you're when we're basing all this
Medical Care off of a survey it's a it's
a huge issue and it's and it doesn't
serve you know it doesn't really and
that's what they're citing to prove that
you know gender affirming care reduces
suicidality my question is uh if they're
using a survey in terms of how they're
Gathering data what do you suggest them
to use a tool than to gather data
because from my understanding a lot of
those surveys are actually more accurate
because folks are actually not in front
of somebody so they're more comfortable
to answer these questions again we can
have a difference of opinion but what
tool then do you suggest folks to use if
they're not using a survey then how do
you gain that data well you're talking
to therapists who can speak not they
can't violate Hippa but they can give
statistics on their on their patients
you can look at see how many people have
entered into facilities because they
were suicidal on that and then you can
go back and see if we give if we gave
these same people gender affirming care
how did it help them I see I see a lot
of again go back to the D transition
Community because we affirm their gender
so much there's so much you know they're
now having issues they're they're you
know contemplating suicide at a higher
level as well great I enjoyed this
debate for what it was you know um it
was quite ugly at certain points and I
wish that it was all trans people on the
panel because that would have been more
appropriate more fitting you're so
offensive
you're an offensive person human being
okay okay well I find a lot of things
over here offensive as well oh wow yeah
you're disgusting and I have to trust me
the feeling is more than Mutual um but I
will say that it was very enlightening
and I hope to be back at Jubilee I
definitely think this was interesting
obviously I don't think we have a lot of
common ground on a lot of things but I
think we found some I think what most
conservatives in general believe is as
an adult you can do what you want with
your body I talk to conservatives all
the time we don't allow children to make
decisions for themselves on a wide range
of issues um and and that's why we don't
let them you know mutilate their bodies
I mean it was yeah like it was
educational enlightening I got to learn
a lot and it's nice meeting on you I
liked hearing the different perspectives
and I feel like even though I'm like
definitely in my beliefs like I
understand where things come from I just
do not agree saying that everybody on
this panel is not trans I think it's
[__] and I think you're trans and
you're a part of my community thank you
y I really appreciate it I despite all
of the madness enjoyed conversation with
all of y'all I love debates we don't
have to agree with each other but these
conversations need to continue happening
because they're not happening anywhere
else and so until we're all creating
more platforms around this for ourselves
so other people can understand then you
know let's keep at it yeah I mean
honestly regardless of my interaction
with Blair here today we are all for the
most part I think mostly in an echo
chamber in our own lives so it's nice
actually to be in front of all these
people especially the ones who don't see
the things the way I do because also
opens my eyes to see you know like maybe
I could rethink XYZ or maybe there's
something I learned today I'm not closed
off to learning something new or to
changing my mind because I've done that
before and I can do that again and I
will evolve as a human being all I have
to say to the general public is start
thinking of reasons why you supported
doing this to kids hello and to that
point
[Laughter]
umus uh it's just I'm hoping that folks
will be able to understand why the
activism is there and what it is because
generally there may be mistakes made in
that light but at the end of the day we
are as trans people trying to gain
access to society in a healthy safe way
and also see a future for ourselves
which is something that I never have
access to with the way that I grew up in
a lot of that ideology of not being
allowed to do things when I was 18 even
though I knew exactly who it
[Applause]
was